good morning everybody earlier this week
the Republican House of Representatives
chose to shut down a government they
don't like over a health care law that
they don't like now I've talked a lot
about the real-world consequences of
this shutdown in recent days the
services disrupted the benefits delayed
the public servants kicked off the job
without pay but today I want to let the
Americans dealing with those real-world
consequences have their say and these
are just a few of the many heartbreaking
letters I've gotten from them in the
past couple of weeks including more than
thirty thousand over the past few days
Kelly Mumper lives in rural Alabama
she works in early education and she has
three kids of her own in the Marines
here's what she wrote to me on Wednesday
our headstart Agency was forced to stop
providing services on October 1st for
over 770 children and 175 staff were
furloughed I'm extremely concerned for
the welfare of these children their
parents who work and who attend school
where are they leaving their children is
it a safe environment are they getting
the food that they receive at their head
start program on the day Julia prudence
application to buy a home for her and
her special-needs children was approved
by the USDA's Rural Development direct
loan program she wrote me from Minot
North Dakota we put in an offer to
purchase a home this weekend
and it was accepted if funding does not
go through our chances of the American
dream are down the drain we've worked
really hard to get our credit to be
acceptable to purchase a home if it
weren't for the direct lending program
provided by the USDA we would not
qualify to buy the home we found these
are just two of the many letters I've
received from people who work hard
trying to make ends meet try to do right
by their families their military or
military spouses who've seen
commissaries closed on their bases
they're veterans worried the services
they've earned won't be there they're
business owners who've seen their
contracts with the government
put on hold worried they'll have to let
people go I want them to know I read the
stories you share with me these are our
fellow Americans these are the people
who sent us here to serve and I know
that Republicans in the House of
Representatives are hearing the same
kinds of stories too as I made clear to
them this week there's only one way out
of this reckless and damaging shutdown
pass a budget that funds our government
with no partisan strings attached
the Senate's already done this and there
are enough Republicans and Democratic
votes in the House of Representatives
willing to do the same and end this
shutdown immediately
unfortunately the far right of the
Republican Party won't let Speaker
Boehner give that bill a yes or no vote
take that vote stop this farce end this
shutdown now the American people don't
get to demand ransom in exchange for
doing their job either dis Congress they
don't get to hold our democracy or our
economy hostage over a settled law they
don't get to kick a child out of Head
Start if they don't agree to take her
parents health insurance away it's not
our our democracy is supposed to work
that's why I won't pay a ransom in
exchange for reopening the government
and I certainly won't pay a ransom in
exchange for raising the debt ceiling
for as reckless as a government shutdown
is an economic shutdown that comes with
default with America not paying its
bills would be dramatically worse I'll
always work with anyone of either party
on ways to grow this economy create new
jobs and get our fiscal house in order
for the long haul but not under the
shadow of these threats to our economy
so my message is simple pass a budget
and this government shutdown pay our
bills prevent an economic shutdown these
Americans and millions of others are
counting on Congress to do the right
thing and I will do everything I can to
make sure that they do Thanks
you